[Music]
amid high profile cases of violence
inside our schools educators and parents
say safety for students and teachers is
top priority now they're demanding
action bianca holmen shares their
frustrations from outside ccsd
headquarters
more than 150 educators parents and
concerned neighbors say they want action
from ccsd leaders if we're going to be
number one for students we need to be
number one for our schools and number
one for school safety this rally comes
after police arrested an el dorado high
school student on charges of attacking
and sexually assaulting a teacher that
16 year old student now charged as an
adult with 15 felony charges
it's just the most recent violent
incident in ccsd schools i can tell you
that every year for the last few years
we've always felt like we're scraping at
the bottom of the barrel morale has been
super low
if we couldn't get any lower last week
was it i'm
really upset by some of the actions that
are not being taken and some of the
approaches that are being taken with
ccoc that i don't know are going to
really make a dent in the major problems
that we have measures they want put in
place include making sure cameras and
intercom systems are operating and
turned on they also want safety plans
published while they say these are
short-term solutions many fear a mass
exodus of teachers and staff if
long-term changes aren't made when you
don't feel safe or if you don't feel
valued you don't put your whole self in
there and many of us are starting to
feel that breaking point students and
staff return from spring break next week
bianca holman live local now